[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette vidéo réaction à une vidéo
qui a fait le buzz à 2 millions de vues
maintenant depuis une semaine une vidéo
de film corps qui s'intitule j'ai ajouté
des dinosaures
scientifiquement plus juste à la saga
Jurassic Park ou anatomiquement plus
correct pour étant dire à la saga
Jurassic Park alors cette vidéo c'est
Stéphane qui me l'a envoyé donc Stéphane
je te salue voilà merci beaucoup de
m'avoir fait remarqué cette vidéo alors
c'est un truc que j'avais vu passer sur
Twitter plein de fois ça a fait beaucoup
de buzz je m'y étais pas intéressé voilà
donc c'est grâce à Stéphane que
maintenant je m'y intéresse parce que il
m'a envoyé donc la vidéo dans laquelle
un sidji artiste donc à quelqu'un qui
travaille avec des effets numériques à
rajouter dans le les films de la saga
Jurassic Park des dinosaures qui sont
donc anatomiquement plus correct en tout
cas c'est ce et justement on va se on va
se regarder cette petite vidéo et
essayer d'en discuter alors cette vidéo
je ne l'ai pas vu là j'ai passé vous
voyez elle fait 14 minutes j'ai passé
les quatre premières minutes parce que
c'est juste introduction introduction
sponso c'est une vidéo YouTube assez
typique de ce point de vue là un tiers
de la vidéo ne sert à rien mais je suis
sûr qu'à la fin ça va être encore abonne
toi mais la cloche mais du coup le le la
vidéo je l'ai pas encore regardé donc ça
va vraiment être une réaction sincère
que vous allez voir ce qui va être
intéressant si vous voulez ça va être de
voir ce qui a changé et d'en discuter et
de s'en servir comme tremplin pour un
petit peu discuter de la science en fait
de la validité de la science qui a
derrière le but c'est pas de débunker la
vidéo évidemment de toute façon quand il
s'agit de remettre de la viande sur des
dinosaures j'ai envie de dire personne a
raison
absolument personne n'a raison un
dinosaure c'est un squelette point voilà
au mieux d'ailleurs au mieux un
dinosaure c'est un squelette au pire on
a que des fragments
donc on va regarder ça
en commençant donc du coup à 4 minutes 3
minutes 52 je vous mettrai le lien de
cette vidéo dans la description afin que
vous puissiez aller la voir si vous le
souhaitez alors évidemment on commence
avec la très iconique scène du T-Rex
j'ai vu quelques quelques artworks du
T-Rex passé sur sur Twitter donc je sais
plus ou moins déjà à quoi il va
ressembler on mettra la vidéo sur pause
on mettra la vidéo sur pause oui
quand on verra bien le T-Rex donc la
première vue première vue du T-Rex
bon c'est du sidji fait maison c'est pas
l'incrustation est quand même pas mal en
fait je veux dire c'est pas non plus
c'est pas hyper dégueulasse
on remarque que les bras sont vraiment
très très petit
voilà on a une bonne vue là hop on va
s'arrêter là on a une très bonne vue du
T-Rex et de ce qui a changé sur notre
T-Rex alors le les deux principaux trucs
je pense qu'on va noter les lèvres
le T-Rex à lèvre ça c'est c'est un truc
dont on va parler aujourd'hui parce que
vraiment l'élève c'est toujours le grand
argument de la discorde et ce qui change
beaucoup c'est la chair là on voit que
le T-Rex il est il a il est massif quoi
il est pas il est pas maigrichon comme
le comme les le T-Rex du film en fait
qui a vraiment que la peau sur les os et
on voit les côtes limite au travers donc
ça c'est vraiment les lèvres et le le
côté un peu massif comme ça un peu un
peu gras du T-Rex c'est vraiment des une
c'est plus un courant de pensée moderne
une mode qui a été lancée par le fameux
livre alliesterdays pour les lèvres ça a
été lancé par le paléontologue Paul qui
est aussi un Paléo artiste donc c'est
presque un courant de mode plus que
réellement un courant scientifique qui
motive ça c'est à dire qu'en ce moment
c'est à la mode de rajouter du gras et
du fluff donc des plumes et Machin sur
les dinosaures et de rajouter des
morceaux de chair et de rajouter des
crêtes et des machins et tout ça c'est
une mode en ce moment qu'il y a de
rajouter plus que dans l'enlever à la
base à la base le scientifique vous dira
le mieux c'est d'en mettre le moins
possible parce que de toute façon comme
je l'ai dit les dinosaures c'est du
squelette donc moins on en rajoute sur
le squelette et plus ça ressemble à ce
qu'on sait donc après tout ce que vous
rajoutez en plus de ça bah c'est de la
spéculation c'est juste de l'imagination
plus ou moins
teinté de raison plus ou moins
plus ou moins argumenté on va dire mais
tout ce que vous rajoutez de viande sur
un squelette c'est de la spéculation
c'est de l'hypothèse de l'hypothèse plus
ou moins raisonnable donc déjà il faut
bien se représenter ça moins on en
rajoute sur notre dîner sur notre
squelette et mieux c'est
scientifiquement parlant je j'anticipe
tout de suite les petits malins oui si
le dinosaure de Jurassic Park était
réellement réel il ferait et il
sauterait au dessus de la au dessus des
voitures et il s'envolerait enfin il
s'envolerait pas il partirait en sautant
comme une grenouille oui les dinosaures
de Jurassic Park sont génétiquement des
grenouilles j'imagine bien le T-Rex là
qui sort de l'enclos est pas bam avec
son énorme sac Guilers
donc oui si les dinosaures de Jurassic
Park étaient réellement réels il ferait
avec un gros sac guère et ce serait très
très drôle mais non on va on va
évidemment partir du principe que les
dinosaures de Jurassic Park sont de
vrais dinosaures pour pour voir
justement discuter de la science qui a
derrière donc
un T-Rex gras pourquoi pas un T-Rex avec
des lèvres on va en reparler là ce
qu'ils ont rajouté c'est les trous pour
les pour les oreilles parce
qu'effectivement les dinosaures de
Jurassic Park on voit pas trop le trou
pour leurs oreilles ils ont poussé la
narine un peu plus vers l'arrière en
accord avec un article qui était sorti
fin des années 90 début 2000 mais qui
avait étudié justement les attaches
musculaires et la cavité crânienne et
ils avaient déterminé à partir de ça que
les narines devaient non pas être sur le
bout du museau mais beaucoup plus
rétracté vers l'arrière en fait
vous voyez que le trou des narines il
fait tout ça donc vous pouvez placer les
narines en bas ici ou en haut là donc là
ils les ont plus placé vers l'arrière
les fameuses lèvres on voit qu'il a
beaucoup moins de dents le master le
muscle Massey terre est différent voyez
que c'est chez dans Jurassic Park à la
base c'est juste une membrane là ils ont
vraiment fait un vrai muscle bien épais
là j'imagine qu'on est plus de l'ordre
de la contrainte technique que de la
contrainte artistique là c'est tout en
Syria donc on peut se permettre des
choses qu'on peut pas se permettre en
réalité en réalité si vous voulez le
problème c'est que vous si vous voulez
rajouter quelque chose ici sur un sur un
animal tronic faut que ce soit très
flexible parce que évidemment
l'animatronique c'est pas vous pouvez
pas simuler de la fibre musculaire en
animatronic c'est un peu compliqué donc
là pour que ça se comporte à peu près
naturellement ils ont utilisé une
membrane plutôt qu'un truc qui ressemble
plus à un muscle plus épais quoi donc là
le muscle masse était à est plus épais
vous avez les petits bras les petits
bras sont vraiment très très petit là
pour le coup beaucoup plus proportionné
comme le squelette avec les pas les
paumes des mains tournées vers
l'intérieur et non pas vers le bas
ce qui est un grand classique de
Jurassic Park de tourner les paumes des
mains vers le bas
donc là elles sont tournées vers
l'intérieur donc ce qui est
effectivement plus correct comme vous
réarticuler naturellement ça se ça se
replace comme ça sur un dinosaure sur un
squelette de dinosaure
la texture de la peau a pas tellement
changé
elle est toujours écailleuse donc ça on
a on a bien vu d'ailleurs sur le sur les
images précédentes la quand il avalé la
chèvre que c'était des gros patchs
d'écailles ça c'est pas ça change pas
donc tout la peau est toujours
écailleuse il y a pas de il y a pas de
plume on va noter du coup l'absence de
plumes qui donc se base sur les le peu
d'empreintes de peau qu'on a de
Tyrannosaurus rex enfin des
tyrannosauridés en général parce que
Tyrannosaurus rex en lui-même on a
vraiment pas des masses d'empreintes de
peau mais on a quelques empreintes de
peau des tyrannosauridés en général
aucune ne porte de plume mais on est
bien d'accord que s'il y avait eu des
mêmes des micros plumes sensitive un peu
comme les poils des éléphants s'il y
avait eu des microplumes sensitif je
pense pas qu'elle se serait fossilisées
donc mais bon ça reste ça reste
relativement correct de ne pas mettre de
plus sur T-Rex c'est des batables mais
ça reste relativement correct là où je
vais là où je vais je pense m'arrêter
plus longtemps c'est sur les lèvres
parce que dire que c'est anatomiquement
plus correct de coller des lèvres un
Tyrannosaurus rex c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai parce que en réalité il y a le
pour il y a le contre donc on a le droit
de faire ce qu'on veut en fait au niveau
des lèvres il y a le pour et il y a le
contre le truc c'est que l'argument en
faveur des lèvres c'est de dire bah les
dents elles auraient craqué si jamais
les elles étaient pas protégées par les
lèvres parce que la desication tout ça
tout ça les crocodiles qui sont les
seuls proches parents des dinosaures à
encore avoir des dents puisque les
oiseaux
les oiseaux sautent aussi des archosores
comme les dinosaures et les crocodiles
mais les oiseaux n'ont plus dedans donc
les crocodiles qui sont les seuls
proches parents des dinosaures à avoir
encore des dents non pas de lèvres donc
les dinosaures étaient par défaut
reconstruit sans lèvres mais les gens
ont dit il y a des gens qui ont dit que
le que les dinosaures théropodes
devaient avoir des lèvres comme les
varans de Komodo par exemple pour
protéger les lèvres pour protéger les
dents de la dessiccation comme ça elles
étaient toujours bien recouvertes bien
bien humides comme ça les mailles elles
ne craquent pas alors ça c'est c'est
vrai dans une certaine mesure mais en
même temps ça fait ressembler votre
dinosaure à un varan de Komodo
or le varan de Komodo n'est pas du tout
approche parent de tyrannosaure is Rex
tous les proches parents de T-Rex encore
vivant aujourd'hui à savoir les oiseaux
les crocodiles et si on est encore un
peu plus aux archéosaures les tortues
aucun n'a de lèvres tous ont un bec et
beaucoup de proches parents de
Tyrannosaurus avec un bec au viraptor
les ornithomyosores les les les Terriens
inosauridés par exemple donc il y a
plein de dinosaures théropodes qui ont
convergé vers la présence d'un bec dont
l'évolution a congé vers la présence
d'un bec
ce qui indique quand même très fortement
que chez les archosores et chez même
chez les archéosaures si on inclus les
tortues j'ai tous beau monde là en fait
tous les proches parents des dinosaures
les lèvres c'est un peu peanuts on s'en
fout ça apparemment c'était pas très
important d'avoir des lèvres et les
lèvres étaient probablement pas là du
tout et c'est pour ça que on a des
convergences évolutives l'argument de
les dents vont craquer si c'est s'il y a
pas de lèvres il ne tient que parce que
on est des mammifères et que chez les
mammifères on a que deux générations
dedans maximum les dents de lait les
dents adultes
chez les dinosaures les dinosaures comme
tous les reptiles mitraillent des dents
tout au long de leur vie
tyrannosaure vous coupez une mâchoire de
tyrannosaure vous voyez qu'il y a au
moins une une deux voire trois
générations dedans qui se succèdent donc
les tyrannosaures ils étaient comme les
crocodiles d'aujourd'hui ils mitraillait
des dents donc
même s'il est dans crack à cause de la
dessiccation on s'en fout puisqu'il en
produit tout le temps et il en produira
toute sa vie donc est-ce que c'est un
réel problème de pas avoir de lèvres
quand on est à dinosaure ma réponse à
moi je pense que c'est non à côté de ça
on a aucun argument solide pour en
faveur de la présence de lèvres on a
aucun argument solide non plus contre la
présence de lèvres mais par contre
l'affirmation c'est plus anatomiquement
correct de coller des lèvres à un
tyrannosaure n'est pas vrai ça par
contre je peux le dire c'est aussi juste
scientifiquement de pas leur mettre de
lèvres tout dépend en fait l'importance
que vous donnez à la aux arguments c'est
à dire que si vous préférez l'argument
fonctionnel à savoir il faut que les
dents restent humides pour qu'elles se
craquent pas bah dans ce cas là vous
allez le faire ressembler à varan de
Komodo mais par contre si vous êtes plus
en faveur de l'argument phylogénétique à
savoir que Tyrannosaurus rex devait
ressembler à ses proches par an bah
aucun des proches parents de T-Rex qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui n'a de lèvres donc
il faudrait le faire ressembler à ses
proches parents d'aujourd'hui
et ne pas lui mettre de lèvres comme le
le Jurassic Park original avait fait
alors voyons voir maintenant un peu
comment il justifie tout ça
le cri chronique du T-Rex
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire là en
fait
ce qui me fait mal ce qui me fait marrer
là en fait c'est que si votre dinosaure
est scientifiquement et scientifiquement
correct là en arrivant devant eux ils
valèrifer les bouffer parce que il va
dire il te verra pas si tu ne bouges pas
oui certes mais il peut te sentir donc
si le tyrannosaure il est effectivement
scientifiquement juste il va arriver il
va renifler un bon coup et il va les
gober
on va voir s'ils ont eu les balls de
faire ça
[Musique]
ah au moins on a une reconnaisse que la
pâte était scientifique qui mange juste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors intéressant je voulais voir la
langue là enfin déjà vous voyez
l'épaisseur des muscles macétaires
effectivement mais là je voulais surtout
voir la langue et donc ils ont rien
changé à la langue c'est toujours une
question intéressante de savoir s'ils
étaient capables de tirer la langue ou
pas les crocodiles ne le peuvent pas
certains oiseaux le peuvent comme les
colibris par exemple mais du coup
c'était intéressant de voir la
flexibilité qu'ils avaient donnée à la
langue mais ils ont pas changé par
rapport au T-Rex du film
ils ont effectivement eu les balls de de
faire bouffer mais par contre ce qu'il a
dit c'est le T-Rex avait la meilleure
vision du monde et peut-être de tout le
de toutes l'existence entière c'est
quasiment ça qu'il a dit c'est à dire
que la meilleure vision de tous les
animaux du monde alors juste parce qu'il
est gros tu dirais que ça avait des gros
yeux donc il aurait eu la meilleure
vision du monde j'ai déjà entendu cet
argument là mais non encore une fois
T-Rex il avait une on ne sait même pas
d'ailleurs à quoi ressemblaient les yeux
de T-Rex faut bien se rappeler j'avais
fait toute une vidéo sur la biologie et
la neurologie et le comportement de
T-Rex où j'avais rappelé assez assez
fermement que on n'a pas d'anneau
sclérotique de T-Rex donc l'anneau
sclérotique c'est ce qui chez les chez
les oiseaux encore aujourd'hui entoure
l'oeil et c'est à peu près la seule
chose qui nous indique à quoi
ressemblait l'oeil d'un animal éteint
donc tous les animaux éteints qui n'ont
pas de danoscléotique comme mammifère on
est cuit on peut rien faire par contre
les animaux tels que les dinosaures
théropodes ancêtres des oiseaux qui donc
eux aussi avaient un anneau sclérotique
eux par contre on a une idée de ce à
quoi leur œil pouvait ressembler grâce à
la noce l'érotique mais le problème
c'est que on n'a pas d'annonce érotiques
de T-Rex donc la grosse affirmation le
T-Rex avait la meilleure vision du monde
vous l'oubliez vous l'oubliez et puis
bon ça connaitre la taille de l'oeil et
la taille de la pupille ce que peut ce
que vous indique l'anus érotique
ça vous donne pas non plus les capacités
visuelles de la bestiole ceci étant dit
il est très probable que les dinosaures
avaient une très bonne vision en
couleurs
j'avais je vous rappelle aussi que il
est possible que le tyrannosaure ait une
très bonne vision nocturne aussi donc
effectivement dans cette condition là
dans la condition du film qu'on nous a
montré juste là
celle là il aurait pu avoir une très
très bonne vision effectivement ceci
étant dit pareil on a on avait rappelé
dans la vidéo sur la Paléo neurologie de
T-Rex que c'est l'aube floculaire donc
un Lobb du cervelet qui contrôle la
stabilisation de la vue n'était pas les
n'étaient pas les plus gros du monde en
tout cas pas comparé à la taille du
cerveau il avait des tout petits lobes
floculaires et donc c'est l'opoculaire
qui normalement on joue un rôle dans la
stabilisation de la vue quand on traque
une proie enfin quand un prédateur
notamment va suivre une proie à la trace
comme ça là
floculaire est en tout petit on peut
faire l'hypothèse raisonnable que
Tyrannosaurus
devait très mal voir les choses en
mouvement ce qui est littéralement
l'opposé en fait de ce qu'on vous dit
dans le film d'ailleurs
dans le film on vous dit il te verra pas
si tu bouges pas bah non en fait au
contraire il te verra mieux si tu bouges
pas parce que si tu te mets à bouger il
va avoir du mal à suivre on va on peut
on peut faire l'hypothèse raisonnable
que T-Rex avec étant donné la taille de
la gueule et la taille des dents qu'il
avait tirex il s'en foutait de des
petits machins lui ce qui chassait
c'était du gros c'était du lourd donc il
a pas besoin d'avoir une vue qui permet
de suivre des petits machins qui bouger
rapidement il a juste besoin d'une vue
qui lui permet de voir des gros machins
qui bougent pas vite
et puis c'est confirmé par par des
analyses éco physiologiques qui ont
reconstitué que le T-Rex il devait
bouffer des centaines de kilos de viande
donc il n'y a pas de centaines de kilos
de viande
à bouffer sur des petites proies en fait
donc même là c'est il y a des gens qui
avaient d'ailleurs fait l'hypothèse que
dans Jurassic Park c'est à peine si
tyrannosaure devrait être intéressés par
les humains en réalité et d'ailleurs
dans le film c'est plutôt bien rendu
puisqu'il s'intéresse en réalité aux
voitures
plus qu'aux humains parce que lui et de
toute façon il a le il a le comportement
qui est réglé là il a tous les potards
réglé sur je veux un gros truc à bouffer
donc effectivement il s'attaque aux
voitures pas aux humains mais bref je
dis graisse beaucoup on voit bien là par
contre d'ailleurs la crête nasale on la
voyait moins tout à l'heure donc la
crête nasale les T-Rex sont une crête
sur le milieu du nez qui est
généralement très très mal rendu dans la
plupart des produits culturels très
populaires donc là on voit bien la crête
nasale et évidemment bien les boss au
dessus des yeux donc ça c'est très joli
et on voit les bras plaqués contre le
corps sur le côté ça c'est pareil c'est
calqué sur les oiseaux et c'est assez
cohérent avec la forme de l'articulation
de la de l'épaule
c'est marrant qu'ils ont en fait
reconstit ils ont refait ça à partir de
la scène ou de genaros fait bouffer
[Musique]
ils expliquent pas pourquoi ils ont fait
ces choix là à là par contre ils
expliquent pour vélociraptor
donc eux ils sont évidemment évidemment
là il explique que vélociraptor était
trop petit et du coup ils se sont basés
sur des nonicus qui était le plus gros
Raptor connu à l'époque depuis on a
découvert Utah Raptor effectivement
bah voilà
donc apparemment ce qu'il a utilisé
c'est
Uta Raptor pour refaire ces vélociraptor
que ta Raptor il a quand même un crâne
qui est beaucoup plus épais
comme ça de but en blanc Utah Raptor
était définitivement recouverts de
plumes ça mérite quand même d'être
discuté puisque aujourd'hui il y a plus
grand monde qui vous qui débattra le
fait qu'il faut mettre des plumes à des
Raptors à des dromés aux oridés parce
que de toute façon les les mais on n'a
jamais découvert de plumes en réalité
sur vélociraptor ou sur Utah Raptor ça
il faut bien le rappeler aussi
Utah Raptor on a que du squelette et
d'ailleurs la plupart des squelettes
qu'on connaît du taraptor ne sont pas
encore décrits donc pour l'instant
Utah Raptor ça reste quand même un gros
point d'interrogation
Velociraptor c'est pas un gros point
d'interrogation dans des découvert plein
en Mongolie on n'a pas découvert de
plumes sur vélociraptor les seules
preuves qu'on a de plumes sur
vélociraptor ce sont des trous dans
l'avant-bras qui correspondent aux trous
qu'on retrouve chez les oiseaux modernes
donc on peut à la limite dire par
l'épreuve direct on peut dire
veloceraptor avait des grosses plumes
sur les avant-bras des grosses remises
avec un avec un rachis bien développé
qui rentrait dans les eaux de
l'avant-bras ça on peut le dire
maintenant d'où vient l'idée que tous
les droméosauridés avaient des plumes il
faut le rappeler c'est juste par
optimisation phylogénétique c'est-à-dire
que on sait qu'il y a des proches
parents de
vélociraptor comme le micro Raptor et on
a aussi des parents plus éloignés des
droméosauridés en général comme les
trous dont il est donc le groupe frère
littéralement c'est les cousins directs
des des dromés aux oreidés les trous
dont idée
tous ces animaux là on sait qu'ils
avaient des plumes grâce aux fossiles
chinois et on sait à quoi ressembler
leur plumage grâce à ses fossiles
chinois et on sait que leurs autres
cousins les premiers oiseaux les
abbesses
avaient aussi un plumage qui ressemblait
à ce qui vient de nous montrer donc là
où la raison pour laquelle on
reconstruit ces droméosaurisés avec des
plumes c'est pas parce qu'on a des
preuves fossiles directes de présence de
plumes chez vélociraptor ou 8 à Raptor
c'est parce que on a les cousins les
proches cousins qui ont été retrouvés en
Chine préserver avec des tissus mous et
donc par optimisation phylogénétique on
fait l'hypothèse raisonnable et à mon
avis correcte
que vélociraptor et Uta Raptor était
fichu de la même façon
[Musique]
c'est intéressant comme question il se
pose la question de l'intelligence donc
il dit
vélociraptor enfin Uter Raptor du coup
puisqu'il va se baser sur Uta Raptor
Utah Raptor donc ressemblerait à une
grosse dinde mais il aurait aussi
l'intelligence d'une grosse dinde donc
en nous montrant une grosse dinde en
train de taper une voiture avec son bec
donc effectivement pour autant qu'on
sache et encore une fois on va on va
faire toutes les hypothèses Paléo
neurologiques qu'il faut c'est si la
taille du cerveau est effectivement
raisonnablement corrélé à l'intelligence
d'un animal
il faut bien se mettre ça en tête que si
et seulement si on fait l'hypothèse que
la taille du cerveau est corrélée à
l'intelligence d'un animal alors les
droméosauridés avaient un cerveau plus
petit
que n'importe quel des n'importe quel
oiseau vivant aujourd'hui même les
autruches le seul le seul dinosaure qui
avait un cerveau de taille comparable au
moins par rapport à la taille du corps
donc le quotient lancéphalisation donc
le seul dinosaure qu'on connaisse pour
l'instant qui avait un cerveau de taille
comparable à un oiseau moderne c'est
trop don en tout cas les trop donc
certains trop dont idée même pas tous
certains trop ontidé probablement
sténonicosaurus qui avait un cerveau qui
en taille comparé par rapport au corps
était comparable à celui d'une autruche
donc l'intelligence d'une autruche ce
qui me suivent sur Instagram sauront que
j'ai une mauvaise histoires j'ai de
mauvais bail avec les autruches
donc non j'appellerai pas les autruches
je ne qualifierais pas les autruches
d'animaux intelligents
et vous ne me convaincez pas du
contraire
donc le maximum c'est ça en fait le
maximum qu'un DIN a pu atteindre c'est
la taille de cerveau d'une autru la
taille du cerveau d'une autruche
et les autruches sont pas les plus futés
des animaux modernes clairement ceci
étant dit est-ce que une autre ruche
serait capable de d'ouvrir une porte
donc si en partant du principe qu'au
maximum ils avaient l'intelligence d'une
autruche est-ce qu'une autruche est
capable d'ouvrir une porte le problème
c'est que les autruches ne sont pas
équipés pour ouvrir les portes
puisqu'elles n'ont pas de doigts elles
sont pas de bras donc ça va être un peu
compliqué pour une autruche je pense
qu'une autruche bien entraînée peut
ouvrir une poignée de porte avec sa
patte
une autruche entraînée vous lui apprenez
à appuyer sur tout surtout une porte
comme ça où il suffit d'appuyer
réellement une autruche entraînée peut
ouvrir une porte ça je pense pas que ce
soit un problème donc mais là il va donc
s'attaquer à la question est-ce que
c'est possible qu'un vélociraptor est
plus ouvrir une porte je pense que c'est
pas un énorme problème le truc c'est
qu'il aurait fallu qu'il le voit avant
au moins qu'il le voit c'est ce que je
dis une autruche entraînée donc il faut
au moins qu'il le voit avant et qu'il
comprenne que le vélociraptor comprenne
le lien entre porte ouverte et
nourriture inside nourriture à
l'intérieur et ça par contre c'est moins
évident c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
évident mais voyons voir ce qu'il en dit
mais ceci dit ça c'est une poule et une
poule c'est beaucoup plus à le cerveau
beaucoup plus gros qu'une
cerveau beaucoup plus gros que celui
d'une autre ruche
alors c'est intéressant là pareil il a
fait le commentaire donc de la pronation
des bras donc effectivement dans
Jurassic Park ils ont les paumes
tournées vers le bas donc c'est plus
facile d'ouvrir la porte là s'il
reconstruit avec les bras alors
techniquement c'est ces trois doigts là
donc s'il reconstruit avec les bras avec
les paumes tournées vers l'intérieur
effectivement c'est plus compliqué ceci
étant dit il faut pas oublier que les
Raptors sont proches des enfin les
droméosaures sont proches des oiseaux
leurs bras c'était probablement pas leur
outil principal il servait plus de leur
tête et de leurs jambes probablement
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont une énorme
griffe sur les jambes c'est parce que il
se servait probablement beaucoup plus de
l'argent que de leurs bras pour attraper
des trucs enfin leurs bras leur jambe et
leur bouche donc je pense que si ils
avaient ouvert la porte les
vélociraptors l'auraient plutôt fait
avec la tête vous voyez ils auraient
poussé la pousser la poignée vers le bas
avec leur bouche plutôt qu'avec leur
plutôt qu'avec leur
leurs bras
ouais on va voir on va voir ça si c'est
donc la fameuse scène la fameuse scène
de la cuisine je suis curieux de voir ça
je suis très curieux de voir ça
alors
il va regarder on va voir le bout de son
pif
c'est pas beau
toujours le
je crois que je crois que je tiens la
miniature là
[Rires]
déjà un dinosaure enfin un raptor
anatomiquement correct en fait ne
regarderai pas par la fenêtre en faisant
face à la fenêtre comme ça parce que bah
déjà il a un museau il a un museau de 20
cm ou même de 30 cm pour 8 heures à
Raptor donc pour regarder par la fenêtre
pour lui c'est vachement plus simple de
d'y coller un seul œil et d'ailleurs il
a les yeux sur le côté contrairement à
tyrex qui a une vue binoculaire donc il
regarde en face de lui les Raptors eux
ils ont pas vraiment une vue extrêmement
binoculaire et ils ont un très long
museau donc eux ils vont plutôt regarder
comme les perroquets ou comme les
pigeons quoi il va regarder de côté
comme ça parce que moi il peut coller
son œil sur la vitre et voir ce qui se
passe donc ça ça déjà c'est pas un truc
qu'un
droméosaure anatomiquement correct
ferait ensuite les lèvres là là la vraie
raison je pense pour laquelle il a un
peu l'air con ce dinosaure c'est surtout
ses lèvres et encore une fois on s'est
débattable on est très très proche des
oiseaux avec avec les droméosauridés ça
ça tyrannosaure encore c'est c'est un
endroit où je mettrai le curseur
vraiment au milieu entre lèvres et pas
lèvres je mettrai le curseur quelque
part au milieu je dirais qu'il y a 50%
de chance qu'il en est eu 50 % de
chances qu'il en est pas eu mais avec
les droméosaures idées on est très très
proche des oiseaux et les oiseaux ils
ont déjà enfin ils ont ils ont la bec
et déjà au Crétacé vous avez Confucius
orniss Confucius orniss il me semble oui
non c'est ça Confucius orniss il avait
déjà un bec il avait déjà un bec alors
il y avait des dents aussi derrière le
bec mais il avait déjà un bec espère
ORNIS avait aussi un bec enfin bref au
Crétacé
au Crétacé il fait déjà pas trop de
doutes que la plupart des oiseaux
avaient un bec donc il est possible que
leur cousins immédiat les droméosaures
et eut aussi très peu de viande sur le
museau était déjà en phase de
convergence enfin en face de d'évoluer
vers la présence d'un deck et donc
toute cette viande là qu'il a sur le pif
ça me rend dubitatif ça me rend très
dubitatif il voyait même les narines là
sont sont très charnues les narines sont
extrêmement charnues alors que les
oiseaux les narines ne sont pas charnues
du tout puisqu'elles sont dans le bec
donc c'est c'est débattable là
honnêtement je pense que je pense qu'on
est assez éloigné de la vérité si je
devais si je devais mettre une note
dessus je dirais qu'on est assez éloigné
de la vérité
la forme des yeux est intéressante on va
pour une pupille ronde mais qui ne
remplit pas totalement le l'oeil
ça se débat
une forme il y a un truc aussi c'est que
la plupart des la plupart des
paléo-artistes refusent de mettre des
yeux des pupilles de chats à leur
dinosaure et parce que ça les fait
ressembler à des serpents et honnêtement
pourquoi pas
surtout le tyrannosaure par exemple si
le tyrannosaure était un chasseur semi
nocturne vous voyez ça aurait pu être
intéressant de lui mettre des pupilles
de chats donc ça mais parce que le
pupilles de chat font ressembler vos
dinosaures à des serpents en fait
ça généralement les Paléo artistes
refusent alors le faire ressembler à un
varan de Komodo en lui collant des
lèvres ça ça passe mais le faire
ressembler à un servant à un serpent en
lui mettant des pupilles verticales ça
ça passe pas c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant c'est tout aussi
spéculatif mais je trouve que c'est un
phénomène intéressant comme quoi ce que
j'essaye aussi de vous dire avec ça
c'est que il y a pas que de la science
derrière le l'exercice du paléohard il y
a aussi des effets de mode il y a un
énorme effet de mode en réalité
donc les Paléo a sont le reflet d'une
certaine culture de leur époque la
bouche est tournée vers le et
bizarrement tourné vers le bas j'ai pas
vu le crâne tout à l'heure j'ai pas fait
gaffe à ça sur le crâne du taraptor
plutôt ce qui nous montre le crâne du
taraptor
voyez sur le crâne du taraptor la
mandibule elle est elle est quand même
bien horizontale donc je sais pas
pourquoi il l'a fait cette espèce de
défait massiakaso russe sur son
sur son Utah Raptor en mettant la
voyez on dirait qu'il allait on dirait
qu'il a la bouche là qui pend vers le
bas c'est c'est curieux
c'est curieux et donc comment il va
faire pour ouvrir la porte
avec ses petits bras ces petits bras
tournés vers l'intérieur enfin c'est
grand bras tourner vers l'intérieur
et bien il la pousse
non donc du coup il est pas allé pour la
bouche tiens là c'est bien fait là c'est
pas cringe là ça va ça va mieux
[Musique]
ok
après il est limité par le film original
au niveau du déplacement des
vélociraptor il va être obligé de les
faire hocher de la tête du coup comme
des poules
[Musique]
mais ouais pourquoi pourquoi cette
pourquoi est-ce que la mâchoire est
tournée vers le bas puis surtout surtout
pourquoi est-ce que la mâchoire serait
tournée vers le c'est un truc bizarre ça
que pourquoi il a fait ça c'est pas
logique en fait
c'est regarder il a la bouche fermée
mais il fait tout le temps
ça lui donne vraiment l'air stupide et
si vous voulez là on aurait eu un
argument intéressant pour dire bah oui
il avait des lèvres pour pouvoir avoir
la bouche fermée quand il fermait la
bouche voyez mais là du coup il non
seulement il lui a collé des lèvres mais
en plus les lèvres mais le problème
c'est que les lèvres elles vont pas
jusqu'en bas du coup et du coup il a
jamais la bouche réellement fermée et
c'est bizarre fabiologiquement parlant
ça n'a aucun sens
biologiquement parlant c'est c'est
chelou là honnêtement
[Musique]
je sais pas pourquoi il a fait ce choix
étrange parce que à varan de Komodo vous
ne verriez même pas les dents du tout
sur un animal un varan de Komodo même
avec la bouche ouverte il y a tellement
de gencives et de et de chair autour des
dents en fait que vous ne voyez même pas
les dents même quand il a la gueule
grande ouverte et là il aurait pu aller
full va rendre Komodo en justement en
rajoutant de la viande à tel point que
même en ayant cette mâchoire tournée
vers le bas là ce masiaka Zaurus effect
il est eu il est eu la bouche fermée par
de la gencive et de la lèvre quand il
fermait la gueule là là ça lui donne
juste là quand il a la bouche fermée il
a la lèvre qui prend encore il a la
bouche il est tout le temps en train de
siffler quoi
c'est chelou c'est c'est un choix
artistique difficilement justifiable
biologiquement donc encore une fois
est-ce que c'est anatomiquement plus
correct je
[Musique]
biologiquement ça n'a pas de sens
bon on notera les plumes ah merde tant
pis on va attendre une un autre shot où
on voit les plumes
voilà en plus ça close-up voilà donc on
notera les plumes avec donc du petit
duvet tout autour de la tête assez
classique avec des grandes remises sur
les sur les avant-bras parce que on a
ces trous sur les avant-bras qui est
effectivement indique que tous les
droméosaures avaient du plumage comme ça
donc ça comme je l'ai dit c'est de le
c'est essentiel à part pour les
avant-bras en fait c'est de
l'optimisation phylogénétique et la
couleur du plumage est relativement
sombre et là
c'est vraiment difficile de sentir la
menace quand même
donc pareil comme pour T-Rex les narines
poussées vers l'arrière comme pour micro
Raptor et archéoptérix par exemple on a
les un espèce de ecodiphérique aussi on
a cette espèce de brosse sur la queue
donc ça c'est ok mais oui donc les live
niveau de la couleur du plumage
maintenant
si on partait vraiment sur du 100%
anatomiquement correct le plumage on
l'aurait fait noir
plus ou moins iridescent en fonction de
vos goûts artistiques mais le plumage
aurait été noir parce que jusqu'à
maintenant en fait quasiment tous les
droméosauridés et les proches parents
sur lesquels on a pu échantillonner des
mélanosomes c'est à dire ce qui donne la
couleur ce qui la mélanine ce qui donne
la couleur au plumes tous ces
mélanosomes
était indicateur d'une couleur très très
foncée du plumage c'est en fonction de
la forme des mélanosomes la couleur sera
plus ou moins foncée
et donc tous les mélanosomes qu'on a
retrouvé chez les droméosaures et proche
parent dans ces fossiles chinois
justement on a des mélanosomes
fossilisées c'est assez ouf indique une
couleur très foncée du plumage avec plus
ou moins d'iris d'essence avec plus ou
moins de parties blanches et rougeâtre
mais globalement on est sur un plumage
très très foncé pas brun là il a il a
fait brun limite roux et non moi je
serais vraiment parti si j'avais été
conseillé scientifique là dessus
j'aurais dit non vas-y noir noir got
gothique à souhait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on notera que Jurassic Park a
visiblement très bien fait les jambes
puisque il ne retouche pas les jambes
[Rires]
pas mal c'est très bien attends je
valide
avec un vrai vélociraptor de 20 cm de
haut c'est plus emmerdant
non bien joué il m'a eu il m'a eu
il m'a eu encore une fois le plumage est
trop clair
et donc la tête
c'est pas mal
on voit qu'il y a pas mal de monde qui
l'ont repartagé qui saute comme une
merde et qui est bas des ailes en plus
donc il vole un petit peu c'est bien et
puis qui se fait éclater la gueule
le spinosaure qui avait quand même cet
avantage dans Jurassic Park d'être déjà
semi-aquatique avant que ça devienne à
la mode de faire des spinosaures
semi-aquatiques donc quand même c'était
pas mal
donc évidemment il réexplique
l'historique des découvertes évidemment
depuis Jurassic Park
sachant que
ouais on a découvert alors du matériel
qui est plus ou moins bien préservé mais
faut pas oublier que quand on vous
montre un squelette complet de
spinosaure comme il est en train de vous
montrer ça reste du composite on a
toujours pas découvert de squelettes
complets de spinosaure donc les
proportions des bras et des jambes donc
avec notamment les gros bras et les
toutes petites jambes de Spinosaurus
ça reste du très très spéculatif la
forme de la crête c'est pareil on a
toujours pas trouvé de crête complète de
spinosaure donc la forme carrée de la
crête opposée à la forme arrondie j'ai
presque envie de dire la forme arrondie
autant que carré sont aussi spéculatives
enfin sont aussi hypothétiques l'une que
l'autre
la forme de la queue plate comme ça par
contre c'est vrai est-ce que spinosaure
était aquatique
on sait qu'il était capable de nager
spinosaure et on sait qu'il avait des
adaptations à la nage spinosaure
notamment au niveau de la densité
osseuse spinosaure a des os extrêmement
dense et ça c'est un pattern qu'on
retrouve chez tous les animaux
semi-aquatiques et très très rarement
chez les animaux terrestres donc
est-ce que spinosaure avait
effectivement ses proportions
bizarroïdes entre les bras et les jambes
avec des très gros bras des toutes
petites jambes pas sûr faudrait quand
même qu'on retrouve des bras associés à
des jambes sur un sol et même squelette
pour en être complètement certain et il
y a eu beaucoup de voix qui ont contesté
ça des voies sérieuses je veux dire
est-ce que spinosaure avait la crête
carrée plutôt qu'arrondit l'un comme
l'autre sont tout aussi et est-ce que
spinosaure était semi-aquat était au
moins semi-aquatique la réponse est oui
ça c'est certain
parce que on a aussi on a aussi le
régime alimentaire de spinosaure qui a
été
reconstitué grâce aux ISO dotopes et qui
a été reconstitué grâce à ses proches
parents comme Baryonyx dont on a
retrouvé des contenus stomaco il est
certain qu'il mangeait au moins au moins
une bonne partie de poisson et
l'utilisation de la queue c'est pareil
pour nager elle est pas certaine mais
bon à partir du moment où vous avez les
eaux qui sont extrêmement denses ça
devient difficile de contester que
Spinosaurus était aquatique au moins en
partie aquatique donc famille aquatiques
sur complètement aquatique comme c'est
représenté là des batables mais il va
falloir attendre plus de matos
Shakespeare si on trouvait chez un
ancêtre des cétacés donc un ancêtre des
baleines modernes si on trouvait les
mêmes caractèresistiques qu'on retrouve
chez spinosaure on aurait aucun mal à
dire ah bah il était semi-aquatique
c'est ce qu'on a d'ailleurs ça existe ça
s'appelle un prototype donc les protocus
rhodossetus
mayasetus tous ces c'est assez très
ancien à quatre pattes on n'a aucun mal
à les reconstituer semi-aquatique en
ayant à peine plus de preuves que ce
qu'on retrouve chez spinosaure mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on y va tête baissée
bah parce que c'est un ancêtre des
cétacés on sait déjà que il y a que
ultimement ça va devenir un animal
aquatique
si on retrouvait ça chez un ancêtre des
hippopotames pareil on dirait bah oui
pas de problème semi-aquatique allez
zouk mais bon si on retrouve ça chez un
animal qui a pas de descendant direct
moderne
et qui du coup n'a pas descendant qui
nous indique très clairement quel est
l'écologie vers laquelle cet animal se
dirigeait au Crétacé
on est coincé donc je pense qu'il y a
quand même suffisamment de preuves pour
dire que Spinosaurus passait clairement
beaucoup de temps dans l'eau on va voir
du coup comment il le reconstitue
[Musique]
parce que il est semi aquatique et du
coup il va ressembler beaucoup plus à un
crocodile
[Musique]
la pire scène de toute la saga Jurassic
celle où le T-Rex se fait bolosser
[Musique]
et je suis d'accord il vient de dire qui
gagnerait entre spinosaure et un T-Rex
c'est T-Rex et ça je suis complètement
d'accord à partir du moment le combat il
est fini quand T-Rex attrape le
spinosaure avec sa gueule
à partir du moment où T-Rex attrape le
spinosaure avec sa gueule le spinosaure
peut faire ce qu'il veut T-Rex est une
machine à broyer son instinct quand il a
quelque chose dans la bouche c'est de
serrer et si le spinosaure se débat met
des coups de griffe lui et lui ouvre le
bidon d'eux avec ses énormes griffes le
T-Rex utilisera tout ce qui lui reste de
force et d'instin pour lui broyer la
nuque
parce que le T-Rex c'est juste une
énorme machine à broyer c'est ce qu'il
fait c'est son job
donc qui gagne entre T-Rex et
Spinosaurus c'est T-Rex même si le T-Rex
finira par mourir de ses blessures le
T-Rex gagnera point barre non négociable
donc qu'est-ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on va se diriger donc vers un
spinosaure qui n'aura pas ça
on va se diriger apparemment vers un
spinosaure qui a pas la craie de carré
mais une crête plus arrondie
pas de crête sur les cervicales parce
que les cervicales on a des vertèbres
cervicales et elles n'ont pas de crête
donc allez vas-y la couche la couche là
donc évidemment la scène où il est dans
l'eau puisque
spinosaure et soumis à côté donc il a
pas changé la forme de la crêpe
donc ça c'est ce que je vous avais dit à
la crête et on n'a pas de crête complète
de Spinosaurus donc on peut la refaire
carré on peut la refaire arrondisse et
tout aussi hypothétique l'un que l'autre
ça ça je suis tout à fait d'accord
[Applaudissements]
et donc effectivement vous voyez c'est
donc lui il privilégie définitivement
l'hypothèse fonctionnelle pour les
lèvres
le spinosaure ne pour lui n'avait pas de
lèvres parce que le spinosaure et
aquatique alors que encore une fois dans
un contexte phylogénétique si il était
cohérent avec lui-même il aurait mis il
aurait mis des lèvres à tous les
théropodes y compris Spinosaurus donc
lui il est clairement de l'école
fonctionnelle et pas de l'école
phylogénétique mais encore une fois
c'est comme j'ai dit le à cette distance
là du cloud des oiseaux parce que
Spinosaurus il est pas du tout il est
même moins proche des oiseaux que
Tyrannosaurus en réalité donc à cette
distance là du cloud des oiseaux
on peut se permettre de faire un peu ce
qu'on veut c'est exactement le même truc
qu'avec T-Rex en fait donc là je suis
d'accord et encore une fois on voit la
langue n'est pas tirée donc pareil pas
trop de mobilité dans la langue
contrairement à ce qu'on peut voir chez
des mammifères par exemple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qu'on va revoir un petit parce que
j'ai vu en fait la position de la narine
est intéressante sur le spinosaure à se
faire mettre juste pour voir la position
de la narine
[Musique]
ça a pas dû être ça a vraiment pas dû
être évident d'incruster son c'est
nouveau effets spéciaux parce que là
vous voyez il y a tellement de bordel au
premier plan comment vous incrustez ça
en fait dans la ça a dû être un boulot
de fou j'ai dit tout à l'heure les
textures font vraiment faites maison
mais mais en réalité ça juste être un
boulot de malade voilà là on voit un peu
la narine juste ici et donc si on
regarde la structure du crâne de
Spinosaurus tel que donner par les
dernières reconstructions on voit donc
ici vous avez l'oeil ici vous avez la
fosse anté orbitaire ça c'est un foramen
alors je sais pas si c'est sensoriel ou
quoi là vous avez des foramens
sensoriels donc des petits trous pour
les nerfs typiquement là aussi vous avez
des petits trous pour les nerfs c'est
pour ça que par exemple dans dinosaure
Planet vous voyez le le spinosaure avec
le pif trempé dans l'eau le bout du pif
trempé dans l'eau bah en fait il a le
bout du pif trempé dans l'eau pour
détecter les proies parce que il avait
des foramens sensoriels donc là je me
demande si c'est pas le foramen septo
maxillaire mais je suis pas sûr je suis
pas sûr de ce que c'est que ce format
mais ne sont pas les narines les narines
ce sont c'est bien ce trou là donc là
effectivement les narines sont très très
rétractées vers l'arrière et ça c'est
pareil c'est une adaptation
classique à un mode de vie aquatique
c'est-à-dire que vous avez les narines
en fait quand vous remontez à la surface
pour respirer quand vous êtes un animal
semi aquatique bah vous avez les narines
le plus haut possible pour que vous ayez
pas à sortir votre tête comme ça et
avoir l'air de galérer donc c'est ce
qu'on retrouve chez on retrouve ça chez
le les vents des dauphins on retrouve ça
chez les dugongs et les lamentins on
retrouve ça chez les plésiosaures on
retrouve ça chez les ictyosaures c'est
une adaptation extrêmement classique de
chez les animaux semi-aquatiques voire
très aquatique et avec un avec un une
narine retroussée à ce point là
il est même plus aquatique en tout cas
il est plus dérivé que ce qu'on voit
chez les phoques par exemple et les
phoques ils sont très très les phoques
et les otaries sont déjà très très semis
aquatiques voire même très fortement
aquatique je crois qu'on pourrait même
dire à ce niveau là qui sont plus
aquatiques que semi-aquatique donc ça
c'est donc là on aurait vraiment une
adaptation à un mode de vie aquatique si
on ne se référer que à la narine on
pourrait dorer déjà dire que spinosaure
était bien plus aquatique qu'un pinypède
donc une
otarie ou qu'un phoque par exemple ce
qui est assez cohérent encore une fois
avec ce qu'on retrouve sur la section
des eaux les os sont très très denses ça
agit comme un ballast qui maintient le
spinosaure au fond de l'eau
donc voilà j'admire quand même le
travail d'incrustation parce que ça ça a
duré bien galère et je pense avec les
flammes après ça doit être encore pire
il a vraiment dû en chier je sais pas si
ça va se voir à ce point
[Musique]
mais il a quand même réussi là avec les
flammes pareil à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit bien du coup la forme de la
Crète de notre spinosaure donc il a pas
mis de crête sur les cervicales
bizarrement il a pas étendu la membrane
jusque là la crête de forme arrondie
pour rester cohérent avec le film d'une
part mais aussi parce que comme je l'ai
dit on n'a pas de crête complète de
spinosaure donc on a encore le droit de
faire un peu ce qu'on veut et je pense
qu'on va voir après la queue qui aura
aussi cette crête très très développée
et encore une fois le spinosaure est
assez
il est assez costaud un petit peu comme
ce qu'on a vu pour le T-Rex tout à
l'heure ça c'est la mode lancé par
olyesterdays de faire des dinosaures qui
sont plus plus vendus on va dire que
plus fat plus gras que les dinosaures
qu'on retrouve habituellement dans dans
la littérature dans dans la littérature
scientifique mais aussi dans les
produits culturels
là on va voir la queue ouais c'est ça la
queue la queue très aplatie
verticalement les proportions des jambes
vous voyez les jambes très petites bien
que encore une fois le film laisse pas
beaucoup de degrés de liberté au niveau
de la taille des jambes puisqu'il faut
quand même arriver à superposer
par dessus le film
ah ouais mais alors là si tu t'attaques
à Jurassic World je vais faire des
dinosaures anatomiquement corrects dans
Jurassic World tu es dans la merde
ah bah oui Giganotosaurus
[Musique]
le dinosaure de Jurassic World
notamment le 3 les dinosaures de les
nouveaux dinosaures de Jurassic World 3
donc notamment Giganotosaurus les
nouveaux design ils sont laids enfin
j'avais parlé du design du listosaurus
par exemple qui était moche mais alors
ouais les nouveaux design moi je les ai
pas aimé mais du tout après les goûts et
les couleurs tout ça tout ça mais
moi j'avais pas aimé du tout moi je
trouvais que c'était des étrons sur
pattes personnellement mais bref
j'avais oublié j'avais oublié ma mémoire
avait sélectionne
on constate aussi que
j'ai pas j'ai pas noté ça trop avec le
spinosaure mais on constate qu'il aime
pas trop mettre des couleurs assez
dinosaures ça reste des couleurs assez
ternes alors que la crête dorsale du
Spinosaurus quand même ça aurait
ça aurait pu être justifiable d'y mettre
des couleurs parce que la crête dorsale
encore une fois la fonction primaire
qu'on pourrait inférer pour cette crête
dorsale c'est une fonction de parade
sexuelle
comme tel qu'elle est utilisée chez les
animaux modernes qui possèdent une crête
dorsale telle que les basilics ils ont
des couleurs très vives notamment sur
leur retraite donc on aurait pu quand
même mettre des couleurs plus vives au
moins sur la crête du spinosaure mais là
là il va vraiment pour des couleurs très
ternes et du coup c'est pareil là on
perd encore une fois sur la
on perd sur le côté de ce qu'on peut
justifier scientifiquement en fait
on aurait pu faire les vélociraples les
Raptors pas les vélociratants mais on
aurait pu faire les Raptors beaucoup
plus noirs ça aurait été
scientifiquement mieux justifié et on
aurait pu faire le spinosaure avec des
couleurs beaucoup plus vives ça aurait
été scientifiquement mieux justifié
alors que là juste le faire avec des
couleurs ternes bah c'est resté sur ce
que Jurassic Park avec déjà proposé en
fait sur ce que les films avaient déjà
proposé
[Musique]
on parle surtout de la taille des
dinosaures mais
encore une fois est-ce que c'est plus
quand on parle de la taille des
dinosaures ce qui est intéressant en
fait c'est de voir ce que les gens
disent quand on dit ah c'est qui le plus
gros bah c'est qui le plus gros dans
quel sens c'est qu'il est plus lourd ou
c'est qu'il est plus long c'est qu'il
est plus long bah c'est spinosaure mais
c'est qui le plus lourd c'est
définitivement direct donc
on pourrait
l'argument enfin la
l'engueulade classique sur la taille des
dinosaures c'était qu'il me le carnivore
le plus gros
c'est juste c'est marrant à regarder
mais j'y participerai pas
alors un giganotosaure
scientifiquement plus juste
[Musique]
voilà c'est surtout la forme du crâne
qui a changé
c'est très très surtout la forme du
crâne qui est beaucoup plus fin
mais
Giganotosaurus le truc c'est que on n'a
pas vraiment de crâne complet en fait de
Giganotosaurus le crâne complet que vous
pouvez voir de Giganotosaurus dans la
plupart des musées etc c'est très
fortement reconstitué et très fortement
inspiré de accrocantosaurus
essentiellement voilà donc le type de
Giganotosaurus et donc les parties en
blanc ce sont les parties qu'on a vous
voyez que il y a quand même au niveau
des proportions si vous voulez il y a il
y a une taille minimum que la que les
dimensions des eaux retrouvées imposent
quoi qu'il arrive donc on sait que
c'était quand même un animal assez
balèze mais on n'a pas un crâne complet
de giganoths de Giganotosaurus donc
c'est pareil il y a un degré de liberté
sur la forme du crâne qui peut être
admise c'est essentiellement basé comme
je disais sur accro sur accro quant
auxaurus et d'autres giganotosauridé
d'autres
d'autres cartes carrodautosoridés mais
en tout cas ouais faut encore une fois
faut revenir tout le temps aux ossements
la précision scientifique vient des
ossements
elle ne vient pas des effets de mode
voilà donc si
à chaque fois vous vous posez la
question de la justesse scientifique
faut pas juste vous référer à ce qui est
à la mode faut vraiment revenir
systématiquement aux ossements et donc
les ossements vous voyez que ça laisse
quand même pas mal de degré de liberté
au niveau du placement ceci étant dit
encore une fois c'est une hypothèse tout
à fait
raisonnable et à mon avis valide de
s'imaginer que Giganotosaurus
ressemblait à un de ses proches par an
du coup j'aimerais bien qu'ils nous
disent encore une fois ce qui a changé
parce que là c'est pas à part la forme
du crâne c'est pas si qui est un peu
plus effilée au final un peu plus fin
c'est pas si évident que ça
puis évidemment les pâtes tourner vers
l'intérieur
d'accord c'est tout
OK et ben ouais il y a le pourri il y a
le contre pour conclure j'ai envie de
dire il y a le pour et il y a le contre
et je pense qu'il y a des fois notamment
sur les lèvres ou je sais pas c'est pas
totalement mérité de qualifier de
scientifiquement plus juste après
effectivement l'orientation des bras
mettre un petit peu plus de viande mais
pas trop je trouve que ça va il est il
est pas allé
il est pas allé full n'importe quoi sur
la quantité de viande ça va tu sais je
m'attendais à des crêtes des machins des
non ça va au final il est resté quand
même assez par simonieux et c'est un
argument qui a enfin c'est un argument
qui a répété très souvent
depuis le livre oliaster days que ah
mais comment pourquoi vous mettez pas
des crêtes et des machins et des pas
parce que si on rajoute des crêtes et
des espèces de sac guère là comme ils
avaient fait dans préhistorique planète
bon bah oui enfin non on peut pas
contester que que ce n'était pas là mais
en même temps si tu commences à rajouter
des trucs sous le prétexte qu'on
contester que c'était pas là tu peux
littéralement reconstruire ton ton
dinosaure comme étant une boule de gras
une boule de viande une boule de plume
une c'est juste une boule quoi et avec
un squelette de dinosaures au milieu
donc faut savoir manier on va dire la
parcimonie
la parcimonie et le la liberté
artistique je pense et les degrés de
liberté artistique que tu as envie de
prendre par rapport à l'hypothèse la
plupart simonieuse qui est vraiment de
juste coller un petit peu de peau sur
les eaux comme ce qui avait été fait
dans le Jurassic Park original voilà
voilà c'était tout pour cette revue de
des dinosaures anatomiquement plus
corrects proposés par film corps je vous
dis à très bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut
[Musique]